un travail minutieux et délicat pour ces
archéologues en herbe au musée
d'archéologie nationale de saint germain
en laye en transmettez ce week-end ses
connaissances c'est un village des
savoir-faire donc l'objectif c'est de
permettre au public de re découvrir les
objets qui sont présents depuis plus de
cent cinquante deux ans au musée
d'archéologie nationale mais sous un
angle un peu différent découvrir la
dextérité des savoir-faire des
populations qui les ont précédés un
village créé pour les journées
nationales de l'archéologie le site
yvelinois proposer une trentaine
d'animations comme on peut pas remonter
le temps on ne peut pas savoir comment
les gaulois fabriquer leurs objets en
verre
donc on va faire des hypothèses depuis
dix ans joël roland étudie les parures
envers une technique que les gaulois ne
maîtrise que 5e siècle avant notre ère
les chercheurs partagent leurs
découvertes
la leçon semble retenue par un jeune
participant il fallait chauffer et un
four à lui à plus de 850 degré qu'on
faisait des bracelets ensuite quand les
élargi chez pour cette 10e journée le
site a accueilli près de 5000 personnes
des découvertes qui ne s'arrête pas au
rendez vous national le masne partage
ses savoirs depuis cent cinquante deux
ans